[Music]  there's something cursed about this land  our family moved west on a promise  a promise that now looked rotten  there's no room for boys in this family  anymore  and no one warned my brother about what  can happen when you dream about destiny  that's how alison wells  entered this story  [Music]  the thief and murderer allison wells  sent five human souls to heaven if you  see this woman  do not confront her  okay  somebody's gonna pay me twenty thousand  to get them to mexico you even imagine  that much money we gotta get all the  farmers and we gotta search  i need to get out of here you're hunting  me  you found her ain't ya it was lady  it's complicated you know the worst part  of dying is king  is being forgotten  it's not safe me being here  [Music]  or for any of us for that matter  i won't be another victim of their lives  scared ass  yeah me too  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign